[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
el ex presidente de sudán omar al-bashir
será enviado a la corte penal
internacional junto con otros dos
funcionarios de su gabinete los tres son
acusados de crímenes de lesa humanidad y
también de genocidio el gobierno actual
de transición en el país confirmó que
entregara al ex mandatario a la justicia
internacional
argelia sufre los estragos de los
incendios forestales que han arrasado
miles de hectáreas en el país
norteafricano al menos 69 personas han
perdido la vida a causa de las llamas y
las pérdidas ambientales y materiales
son incalculables
y se realizaron elecciones
presidenciales se ensambla la ciudadanía
espera que el nuevo mandatario pueda
hacer frente a la crisis económica que
se vive en el país agravada además por
la pandemia de kobe 19
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días él es
presidente sudanés omar al-bashir será
entregado a la corte penal internacional
así lo anunció el jefe de la cartera de
relaciones exteriores del país un ex
gobernador y un ex ministro de defensa
también serán entregados al tribunal
internacional todos sospechosos de
cargos de genocidio y crímenes de lesa
humanidad
omar al bachir fue derrocado en 2019
tras meses de manifestaciones ciudadanas
y 30 años en el poder el nuevo gobierno
de transición se ha caracterizado por
modernizar el país y dejar atrás la mano
dura del ex mandatario
escapó de la corte penal internacional
durante años viajando libremente a
países que no tenían intención de hacer
cumplir las órdenes de detención en su
contra pero esos días se acabaron en
2003 estalló una guerra civil entre los
grupos rebeldes locales y el gobierno
central en darfur la corte penal
internacional acusó a omar al bashir de
genocidio y crímenes de lesa humanidad
durante el conflicto un año después en
300 mil personas murieron y casi dos
millones y medio resultaron desplazadas
según las naciones unidas
desde el momento en que la haya emitió
su primera orden de arresto contra el
bachiller en 2009 el entonces presidente
sudanés se lamentó por ello
su objetivo es obstaculizar el
desarrollo de sudán
wilders de luna están tratando de
desestabilizarnos con sus asuntos y
acusaciones pero no los dejaremos
en abril de 2019 después de 30 años de
gobierno sobre sudán omar al-bashir fue
derrocado a raíz de protestas masivas
contra el gobierno
[Música]
unos meses más tarde el ejecutivo de
transición no sentenció a dos años de
prisión por un caso de corrupción y
también se comprometió a entregar al
dictador depuesto a la corte penal
internacional
las autoridades de salud en guinea están
en alerta después de que se confirmara
un caso del virus de marburgo una fiebre
hemorrágica altamente infecciosa similar
al de bola las tasas de mortalidad de
marburgo en brotes pasados han variado
entre el 24% y el 88% de los contagiados
las autoridades sanitarias de guinea
están monitoreando a 155 personas que
pueden haber estado en contacto con el
positivo confirmado en que quedó en el
sureste de guinea se trata de la misma
región que dio origen al brote de ébola
en área occidental entre 2014 y 2016 el
más mortífero de la historia estas
fueron las palabras del director de la
organización mundial de la salud pedrosa
damos de abre jesus
barbour es un virus muy diferente al que
causa a kobe 19 pero muchos de los
elementos de la respuesta son los mismos
aislar y cuidar a los infectados
rastrear y poner en cuarentena sus
contactos e involucrar a las comunidades
locales en la respuesta no existe una
vacuna autorizada para marburg aunque
hay vacunas en desarrollo y la ms está
trabajando con nuestros socios para
buscar oportunidades para evaluarlas
durante este brote a través del plan de
i + d para las epidemias los incendios
forestales en argelia ya deja más de 69
muertos entre ellos alrededor de 30
soldados que intentaban extinguir las
llamas otros dos oficiales resultaron
heridos el ministro del interior- culpa
a pirómanos de haber iniciado las
comparaciones sin ofrecer una evidencia
son uno de los incendios más
destructivos en la historia de argelia
decenas de incendios arden en el país
afectando principalmente el norte del
territorio dejando decenas de muertos el
fuego ha derribado casas y ha obligado a
cientos a buscar refugio el área más
afectada es tizi ouzou en la región de
cabilia
como verán al fuego en todas partes no
hemos visto el gobierno acá no tenemos
un estado la gente es el gobierno viva
los miembros del equipo de protección
civil
entre los fallecidos hay soldados que
les salvaron las vidas civiles y
lucharon para combatir los fuegos otros
quedaron con heridas de gravedad el
presidente de esta nación se pronunció
al respecto con profunda tristeza y
dolor recibo la noticia de la muerte de
25 miembros del ejército nacional
popular luego de que lograran salvarle
la vida a más de 100 ciudadanos de los
incendios en las montañas de beja ya it
is you show en medio de esta tragedia
rogamos por las almas de los héroes de
esta nación
funcionarios del gobierno han culpado a
pirómanos de haber dado inicio a las
quemas sin embargo no ofrecen evidencia
y se comprometen a compensar a los
afectados
como habrán notado y bajo las directivas
del presidente de la republica una
delegación ministerial conjunta visitó
estas áreas esta mañana para conocer la
magnitud de las pérdidas y la magnitud
del desastre confirmamos que el estado
los compensará total completamente por
estas pérdidas
de orgullo una ola de calor ha agudizado
los incendios forestales en la región
del mediterráneo afectando gravemente
también a grecia italia y turquía se
realizaron elecciones presidenciales en
sangre de ciudadanos en todo el país
dieron largas filas para acudir a las
urnas y unos comicios generales que se
celebran bajo la sombra de una fuerte
crisis económica y la represión
creciente contra las disidencias
políticas en los últimos años
si bien un total de 16 candidatos
presidenciales participaron en esta
contienda electoral se espera que los
resultados estén en una manera muy
reñida entre el actual presidente y
candidato del gobernante partido
patriótico edgar longo y su principal
opositor haq i'm the gipsy lema del
partido unido para el desarrollo
nacional veamos el informe
[Aplausos]
apenas salió el sol sobre lucas a
decenas de votantes envianos ya estaban
en la fila
una señal de la impaciencia de toda una
población que cada vez tiene más
dificultades para llegar con recursos a
fin de mes
la razón por la que quiero votar es que
la economía va mal cíclico no me va mal
estamos sufriendo
no hay trabajo estamos ansiosos por
elegir un nuevo líder para que pueda
crear puestos de trabajo
16 candidatos participaron en la carrera
pero esta elección representa en
realidad un duelo entre dos hombres
por un lado edgar lugo en el poder desde
2015 y por otro su rival de toda la vida
a kyle de xilema que aparece por sexta
vez el presidente lungo es acusado por
sus detractores de haber hundido a su
país al embarcarse en malos proyectos de
infraestructura y pidiendo préstamos
insostenibles especialmente a china la
pandemia de kobe 19 también ha pasado
factura
zambia segundo productor africano de
cobre ha sufrido la caída de los precios
de las materias primas
a finales de 2020 el país se convirtió
en el primero del continente en no pagar
su deuda externa exponencial estimada en
10 mil millones de euros
pasamos a temas económicos porque
camerún ve amenazada su producción de
cacao a causa de la extrema sequía este
país es el cuarto productor de cacao más
grande de áfrica después de costa de
marfil ghana y nigeria que le llevan una
gran ventaja hoy enfrenta una dura
batalla para cumplir su objetivo a largo
plazo de subir la producción anual de
cacao a más de las 300.000 toneladas que
produce hoy en día esto debió las
amplias temporadas de sequía de áfrica
occidental y de áfrica central proviene
alrededor del 70% de los granos de cacao
del mundo
y así será
ha habido cuatro meses de sequía aquí se
ve todo está chamuscado es tener una
plantación productiva ahora todo está
quemado tres hectáreas destrozadas por
la sequía eso se debe a que la temporada
seca duró más de seis meses a quién
quién que por eso no tenemos suficiente
cacao en este momento también encierran
león agricultores intentan recuperar una
exótica especie de café que sólo se
encuentra en sus montañas trata del café
este no fila el cual se creía extinto
nuevos hallazgos de plantas representan
una nueva esperanza para la economía del
país
llevamos dos horas caminando por las
colinas del campus
y ahora nos acercamos al jardín de
exterior de lula salvaje wild garden
hace unos meses aquí es donde daniel
salomón agrónomo y un equipo de
investigadores de hugh arden si la
universidad de greenwich
este es un café tó éste no fila
este es uno de esos árboles que están
dispersos por todo el bosque pero una
forma de reconocerlos es mirando la
punta de sus hojas cultivaba hasta
principios del siglo 20 en áfrica
occidental y especialmente apreciado por
los comerciantes europeos
el café este no fila se servía en las
mejores mesas de parís pero al ser
demasiado raro y caro fue sustituido
gradualmente por el arábica y el robusta
se cree que ha desaparecido por completo
desde 1954
de 2013 a 2018 buscamos y nos dimos
cuenta de que sólo crece a una altura de
400 metros sobre el nivel del mar así
que llegamos a este bosque subimos y
finalmente vimos tres o cuatro árboles
el café se cultiva en sierra leona desde
hace pero en cantidades muy pequeñas el
país lucha por hacerse un hueco en el
mercado mundial solo es el decimonoveno
exportador de café de áfrica con el
redescubrimiento de la este no fila las
esperanzas son altas consciente de la
ganancia financiera que podría
representar dentro de unos años graham
billington un ex comerciante de
diamantes que se ha volcado en la
exportación de café y cacao ha invertido
en una granja para intentar reactivar el
cultivo
este café es un tema candente en este
momento porque podría salvar la
producción mundial de café que está
colapsando con el calentamiento global
pero también porque tiene una verdadera
identidad un sabor único pero en que se
benefician los cierra leoneses en los
límites de la selva las comunidades que
viven en condiciones precarias temen que
este tesoro se les escape estamos muy
contentos por el redescubrimiento de
este café
pero viene de aquí de nuestros
territorios por lo que pedimos al
gobierno que nos permita participar en
su desarrollo para que también podamos
aprovecharlo para vivir mejor en sierra
leona un pequeño caficultor gana una
media de ciento al año por ello las
autoridades esperan que la estén off y
la abra un nuevo mercado próspero y
justo para sus agricultores
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde francia porque me hd y está cola
presentan el videoclip de su nueva
canción titulada pololo es sencillo
rescata las raíces africanas de ambos
artistas y pone el afro trap de nuevo
los primeros lugares de las listas de
reproducción tanto en europa como en
áfrica así finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días pero ustedes pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
con más información
una vez
[Música]
sí no
mejor
la página bajo
mejorado
[Música]
colo colo
colo colo colo